I tell people my sister moved out west
their science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down that's not my
story
before I was an Avenger I mean mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
is callsigns taskmaster he controls the
Red Room there manipulated fully
conscious but no choices I should have
come back for you hold are the others
are there enough
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win I was founded best
look into the past
okay you gonna plan what shall I just
stayed up in coach my plan was to drive
us away Blair your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
who you are
I mean my choice
are you done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch I'm not slouching you're going to
get the back hunched listen to mother oh
my god alright enough all of you I
didn't say anything that's not fair
[Music]